2000 c'est le nombre de films inscrits
au short film corner un espace
uniquement dédié aux courts métrages ont
plein coeur du palais des festivals ici
le court métrage est un passage quasi
obligé pour les réalisateurs c'est une
manière de faire ses preuves c'est
également l'occasion de se faire
connaître auprès des professionnels avec
son film jeanne l'yvelinois nicholas
kamm sauf a été sélectionnée pour le
short film corner le jeune homme de 22
ans réalise ainsi son rêve et nicolas
aurait peut être pu faire carrière dans
le football si une blessure à la jambe à
l'âge de 13 ans ne l'avait pas obligé à
abandonner les terrains et à se tourner
vers la vidéo le montage puis la
réalisation nicolas a désormais trouvé
sa voie on commence à faire des vidéos
des vidéos je m'étais dit pendant deux
ans ça y est c'est ça que je veux faire
je pu faire du montage c'est faire de la
réalisation donc c'est devenu une
passion presque
presque addictives vraiment c'est
obsessionnel sais j'ai besoin de faire
des films tous les ans j'ai besoin de
créer quoi donc c'est venu comme ça et
je suis très très content de pouvoir
faire d'ici un an après on dit pas
forcément de sa passion mais en tout cas
faut qu'elle essaie de casser les murs
et pour casser les murs il met toutes
les chances de son côté nicolas qui n'a
pas fait d'études de cinéma est un
autodidacte et veut se faire connaître
l'an passé il était déjà venu présenter
à cannes un film sur le football amateur
il a pris au bout d'un moment les gars
faut se poser la question qu'est ce que
je veux devenir qu'est ce que j'allais
devenir dans le football le droit à
l'eau plus de niveau international
aujourd'hui nicolas roviens short film
corner l'espace dédié aux courts
métrages avec un autre film visionnable
par l'ensemble des festivaliers le plus
grand intérêt c'est le pouvoir avant
tout projeter des films qu'on peut avoir
des salles de projection dont il
présentait des films et des producteurs
et puis aussi d'avoir un outil carte de
visite aussi faut pas se mentir le
champion canard est un bon marché pour
on va dire des marchés d'autres
festivals internationaux et aussi bien
nationaux ou régionaux dans notre pays
pour moi c'est le premier intérêt d'être
au short film corner il observe on sait
devoir faire des rencontres en tout cas
dans notre milieu des acteurs des
producteurs des distributeurs nicolas
est donc descendu sous le soleil de la
croisette pour défendre son deuxième
court métrage jeanne l'histoire de gaël
un ancien cambrioleur et qui s'évade de
prison pour aller se recueillir sur la
tombe de sa mère et à travers sa cavale
il entreprend une quête du pardon envers
ses proches et lui même
j'existe pas si jamais tout à
gueugnon accessoires
oh
s'y mêlent et mios et rapidement parce
que on va dire je voulais rendre hommage
à ma mère pense que bon même si elle
n'est pas morte et que celle ci mette à
ses romances et on va dire que ça
j'avais été souvent eu des rapports très
conflictuels avec ma mère ce qui a fait
que jouer un petit peu me pardonner on
va dire envers ma mère parce que je n'ai
pas été un enfant très très facile et
donc du coup j'ai fait ce film là pour
elle et puis essayer de aussi sur le
plan artistique de passer un cap et
d'évoluer pas ce qu'il fallait je suis
décidé de produire ce film a tout seul
et toutes ces économies sont passées
tourner ce film de 15 minutes lui a
coûté plus de 3500 euros pour passer à
l'étape suivante nicolas doit maintenant
boucler un budget plus conséquent afin
de réaliser son premier long métrage
baptisé provisoirement frater c'est un
film
qui est qui devrait parler de la
banlieue alors j'aime beaucoup faire des
films sociaux on va dire essayer de
faire montrer en faire montrer des
messages à faire passer des messages de
société qui sait ce sont des thèmes qui
me parlent vraiment et c'est pour ça que
je vais faire un film sur la banlieue en
tout cas je l'espère année prochaine à
seulement 22 ans le jeune homme qui vit
à mantes la jolie et déterminés à faire
de sa passion son métier nicholas kamm
saufs a pour devise une citation du
petit prince d'antoine de saint-exupéry
fait de ta vie un rêve et d'un rêve une
réalité